hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um october 25th
2021 what's going on how are you
how's life in your world
how is it going with you it's gonna be
[ __ ] raining like a [ __ ] out
here
in los angeles
all day long it never it never rains in
california
during this time of year but there's
plastic bottles in the ocean yeah we're
having weird weather
weird weather i was at the gym the other
day beefcake beefcake
and um
you know they got the weather on right
names we have the news on not saying
that weather isn't news
okay i'm not trying to make it seem like
people are more important than mother
nature
isn't that typical what is it because
mother nature is a woman
um
this [ __ ] weather man is basically
describing the end of the world
big smile on his face he's like well
with climate change
we're going to have what's known now as
uh whiplash weather
the droughts are going to be more severe
the
rainstorms are going to be more
punishing
and the ladies just like okay all right
great you know the [ __ ] lady at the
desk like everything was [ __ ] cool
and no point is he's like hey you know
maybe you don't need [ __ ] 50 flat
screens in your house
you know maybe you should stop
post-mating [ __ ] and you know so you get
your [ __ ] burger and it comes in a
plastic container and then you throw it
out and you just had a [ __ ] burger
and then the plastic container is going
to be in the ocean for [ __ ] eight
hundred thousand years
nope can't do that we don't want to
upset
our listeners
so
i don't know there's a few things i
heard there's like some [ __ ]
grocery place out here
that will bring your you your food and
everything and it's all in like i don't
know
glass containers and then you return it
like the old old school days
um
i want to say most of those companies
that are doing that are younger people
thank god you know because they know
that they're gonna have to try to
[ __ ] live a full life here
and um
you know
older people don't give a [ __ ]
i've been using plastic my whole life
why does he have to be southern bill all
right dude i've been using [ __ ]
plastic my whole life let's not [ __ ]
raspy my goddamn voices
smoked a cigar last night and um
i feel right back to being run down this
[ __ ] cold i can't shake because my
kids keep giving it to each other and
you know what i realized i mean after
this [ __ ] podcast i'm grabbing all my
cigars sticking them in a bag and i'm
throwing them in the [ __ ] trash i'm
done with them
bill say it ain't so it is so i'm done
with them i'm not having them around my
[ __ ] house
you know like i'm [ __ ] wc fields or
some [ __ ] all right from here on out if
i want a [ __ ] cigar i have to go out
and go get one
go down to a goddamn cigar bar but i am
not having these [ __ ] things laying
around like cheez-its
you know
oreo cookies or some [ __ ] that i'm just
gonna [ __ ] devour
um
i mean i've gone like nine days
this is the weirdest cold ever nine
[ __ ] days
and one i only had a nub i just had a
little nub
not hurting anybody
[ __ ] cigar the size of your thumb
and i was wired i couldn't [ __ ] go to
sleep
[ __ ] playing some stupid game on my
phone till like 2 30 in the morning and
this whole day i'm not gonna be worth as
[ __ ]
i mean listen to this podcast it's
[ __ ] terrible
no
um
no i'm done i'm done with these [ __ ]
things in my house that's it
i have to do it now when i'm [ __ ]
done as opposed oh look at that they're
so beautiful now i know somebody's going
like
why are you going to throw them out bill
why don't you come to one of your
friends you know why because there's a
million [ __ ] cigars that's why
all right there's a million
[ __ ] cigars
you know
and why would i give them to somebody
else so they can [ __ ] go through what
the hell i'm going through
yeah i'm all in your goddamn house and
[ __ ]
um anyway
um
let's talk nfl football
dude
[ __ ] jets man jesus christ
they got the living [ __ ] kicked out of
them by the new england patriots
winning 54
to 13. somebody explain to me
when the jets are ever not going to be
the jets those poor goddamn fans
i mean i don't even know
they're thinking okay tom brady's gone
we got a shot here mac jones he's he's a
rookie we can we can [ __ ]
you know
we can make this guy nervous
right
passing
let's see we got to let's see what let's
see what mac jones did yesterday i'll be
honest with you i saw about two seconds
of this game
307 yards 24 for 36 370 yards
two touchdowns
they even put the backup in in the end i
think
went three for four for 79 yards he
almost got to triple digits
spread the ball around nice
not one 100-yard receiver look at that
he's [ __ ] spreading it all over the
goddamn field
tree mendes
um
how about jawad
bentley
that guy's looking like a [ __ ]
all-pro i don't know how the hell
somebody let him go i think we picked
him up as a free agent
guys all over the goddamn field every
time i've been watching bill why didn't
you watch yesterday because i have to do
a whole rewrite of a script by thursday
120 pages you got to get it down to
about 90. still have the story make
sense so i've been [ __ ]
busting my ass on that
which is literally what i'll be doing um
after uh after the podcast today let's
just go right into that [ __ ] but then
it'll be done on thursday
you know the clouds part a little bit
you know i did last night because of
this [ __ ] rain right
so as they say it never rains in
california well
what happens is
when it does rain because the soil is so
dry that's why we get like these
mudslides and [ __ ]
and um
you know they [ __ ] block up your
drain pipes and all that [ __ ] so
yesterday
as the sun was going down i heard about
this [ __ ] epic storm that's supposed
to be coming i was like oh [ __ ]
so i was up there cleaning out the
gutters um
digging up all like trying to figure out
each each yeah i swear to god each
little drain thing had a different cap
but i had to figure out how to get the
thing off
you know only broke one of them
so it's cleaning the things out right
i got two screwdrivers a couple of
spoons and a big [ __ ] ladle looking
thing
from the kitchen hoping my wife doesn't
come out like you're using the stuff we
eat with
uh yeah sorry
sorry i don't have the [ __ ]
equipment i need you know i had to go i
had to go with one of these plastic one
of those those spoons i got the holes in
them i went with the plastic one it
didn't fit down any of the drain so that
was all right but uh i got to tell you
something i'm just living out here the
reptilian [ __ ] uh
presence
it's pretty scary to stick your hand
down one of those things and i'm just
thinking no spiders no spiders no
spiders and i pull it out i see this
spider go running by you know those
little bastards too man they'll give you
a [ __ ] wealth they'll climb right up
on you while you're sleeping
the next day you don't know what you got
your what is uh
what does it look like when we put a
[ __ ] cigar out on my arm it's a
spider crawling up on you so
it's kind of unsettling i'm not going to
lie to you like i was doing it at night
you know and i could barely see
because i'm an idiot do it yourself dad
so i hope i did it enough
i mean the drain out in the front of our
house
literally had like little [ __ ]
flowers starting to come out of it
and i was just like why do i always wait
until the storm to look at these [ __ ]
things so
we'll see what happens
i'm already picturing my wife later on
today bill
bill the water's coming up
oh yeah you can't push a broom
you can't make it go down the driveway
um
it's one of those damsel in distress
moments when the water's coming up yeah
so last night
i'm sitting out on my porch and i have
just a little time the tiniest little
[ __ ] cigar the size of my intellect
right and i'm just sitting out there
and i noticed when i went by my um
my trash barrel
that there was um
these weird paw prints
you know on the um
you know near like the trash barrel and
i'm sitting there going those don't look
like like cat paw prints
what are those things like i think
that's a [ __ ] raccoon
you know and i'm thinking like those
things come down
i got to get simply safe
because i want to i want to i'm going to
do a reality show of the varmints
that come down near my trash can we got
opossums
oh oh geez we got possums
we got uh
raccoons i got coyotes that's a canine
it's not a varmint
um
and then you know there's a couple of
mountain lions out here one or two
in los angeles you're thinking like all
right well i'm not up in the hills i'm
not going to see these [ __ ] thing but
then like
i saw this youtube video of somebody
like the thing
well they were on the second floor and
this thing was walking across
from balcony to balcony like right on
the edge where you would look over like
a freaking house cat
so
last night i'm sitting out there smoking
my cigar like an idiot like an idiot
stamper you idiot
um
and all of a sudden i see the shadow of
the biggest [ __ ] cat i've ever seen
in my life and i go oh my god that's it
it's the [ __ ] mountain lion and then
i looked down and it's some [ __ ]
house cat that just walked in front of
this light and it threw a big shadow on
the wall
every time i go out to my garage at
night i think about that mountain lion
every
[ __ ] time
um
so anyway
uh
yeah so i'm sitting there and i'm like
all right it's just a house cast it's
just a house cat
cat right and i'm sitting there smoking
my cigar and nia was out there right
and um
we're just [ __ ] talking like checking
in with each other
because that's like something that can
happen you know i notice once you get
married and you have like two kids
like if you don't check in with each
other after 10 days it's you're going to
become like strangers
it gets [ __ ]
it can get scary really quickly like i
really see how people
um
how it all falls apart
it's so [ __ ] it can happen so fast
and then i got that thing like if i'm
not connecting with somebody i just go i
you know remember rivas island speaking
of the jets
i go to billy island right byland
bill byland i just go out on my little
[ __ ] thing my little loner i'm out
here by myself nobody can hurt me all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] i did before i became a
comedian i go right out into that
[ __ ] thing
and i just become like a like a
self-sustained unit and then i start
passing my wife in the halls like i'm
like at [ __ ] ikea or something
um
so like what are we doing what do we
have we have we gotta have [ __ ] lunch
every week that's what we got to do
reconnect you know we got to get it
going
so um
we ended up hanging out laughing having
a great time and i was like oh it's good
we're connecting again
i [ __ ] love her this is awesome and
then all of a sudden we just hear this
thing growling
like a little [ __ ] roar not a big one
but enough to make the [ __ ] if you
had hair on your head
which i don't stand up make the stubble
stand up right next time i'm gonna i
wish i recorded that [ __ ] growl
next time i shaved my head i would play
it
i'd get the closest shave ever
and uh i think it was a [ __ ] raccoon
and i wasn't sure if it was upset that
we were out there
because it was [ __ ] with its ability
to come down
and check out you know if we threw out
anything yummy in the trash
or if it was you know dealing with its
territory
it saw something else i have no idea
what it was
you know i don't think possums make that
let me let me [ __ ] look this [ __ ] up
i gotta find out what that
was oh [ __ ] uh billy raccoon hunter
here
raccoon
growl
jesus christ i can't even spell growl
g-r-o-w-l raccoon growl
stabs and growls rack tutorial what
jesus christ didn't even spell raccoon
the [ __ ] you know
again when you put your fingers on the
keyboard you got to make sure it's the
right sound all right let's let's let's
listen to this [ __ ] here
all right
that's what the [ __ ] it was
yeah that's what it was i'm just sitting
there smoking a cigar talking my wife
and all of a sudden we hear this
that's it
there you go now you got a little
[ __ ] cry you know which i know
probably doesn't sound like much to you
as you're sitting there
you know
with your suit on and no pants waiting
to start your [ __ ]
zoom meeting or whatever the hell you're
doing yeah that's what i heard in the
trees
you know
and uh my wife was like all right i'm
going inside
[Laughter]
it was a death champ bit the black
person was like hey i'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here and i was the white guy
going that's up in the trees it'll be
fine
hey nick get me a piece of bread i want
to try and feed it
i'm not that dumb i really don't i don't
uh
old freckles does not [ __ ] with nature
okay it's not something
that i'm into
all right um i know all of these goddamn
things squirrels or anything man if they
jumped on me the damage that they could
do how quick they are
okay
how quick those [ __ ] things are the
amount of my ear that could be gone by
the time i even my brain was like bring
hand up to knock whatever that is off
shoulder
um
yeah i don't [ __ ] with that stuff at all
so
um
anywho
um yeah so this guy was just sitting
there just describing
you know i'm on at the gym you know
because i'm [ __ ] dropping two pounds
a week that's my deal until the end of
the year then i'm gonna be in shape and
i know i've been saying this for a year
but now i have the time to do it so
that's what's gonna happen it's not a
question i'm only trying to do two
pounds a week what i usually do is i try
to do three pounds a week and then what
ends up doing it gets me dehydrated i'm
[ __ ] doing all this [ __ ]
elliptical
you know and i get burned out then i
gotta go on the road i'm like i've been
good
do they have a late night menu right
can i get the steak and cheese
and the [ __ ] banana split please
i've been good
you know in one meal
i negate all the [ __ ] cardio i did
that week and then i come home and i'm
like
why are my button downs you know making
me feel like i'm in a relationship i
have to get out of
you know like you know you're coming on
too strong this is suffocating okay it's
just i'm not saying i don't like you
but
it's kind of just stopping there
oh god where were those lines when i was
in my 20s you know what i mean you just
[ __ ] make it quick and easy that's a
great line
listen it's not that i don't like you i
like you okay it's just not progressing
past that
well what if i learned to juggle or or
what if i started like cooking if i
added some skills to my resume
ma'am what if you went out and found the
person
that's going to love you for who you are
bottom lip is quivering
you know i'm sorry it's not me i wish it
was but it just isn't
and
you know
i want to find that and i want you to
find it
okay
so that's it see that's how hard the
last line's always hard
and i'm out you know you got to have
that smooth
that smooth transition and you just
don't
dude speaking of smooth
[ __ ] transitions
wait i gotta finish this weather thing
all right
i gotta finish this [ __ ] weather
thing
so
um
all i was thinking when i was watching
that
when i was watching that weather
aside from the obvious what kind of
world are my kids going to be having
with whiplash weather
and how much crazier is this going to
get
i was just thinking like
you know what is that going to do to
aviation
you know when this weather really starts
getting [ __ ] crazy super [ __ ] hot
super windy and all of that [ __ ] you
know it gets too hot you can't fly
the air molecules there they're all
[ __ ] spread out right you can't get
lift
and um
severe turbulence and all of that will
these are these planes designed
to handle whiplash weather
which is what they're going to call it
and then everybody's going to say it
enough times just like climate change
and like you know they say well you know
with climate change it was literally
something that [ __ ] they were saying
wasn't happening people were denying it
and now these [ __ ] [ __ ] are just now
saying it
on the news like it's no [ __ ] big
deal like we don't all need to make a
[ __ ] hard left or right here before
we hit the brick wall
so anyway i'm sitting there
thinking about this and it's just like
this is really going to affect travel
that is what i do for a living
what will that mean to me and i was just
like
thank god i'm a frugal son of a [ __ ]
because i had my biggest tour
of my career next year and i told my
wife it's like i'm buying one pair of
pants
and two shirts oh billy banking it
you know whatever they let me [ __ ]
keep out here in california
you know
but you know i'm not moving to [ __ ]
montana or wyoming i'm not doing that
[ __ ] i'm not going they don't want me
there and i don't want to be there i
respect that but they don't want me out
there
you know what i mean
they don't need no east coast guy coming
out there with his entire racial family
i'm not doing that i'm staying out here
um
so i'm [ __ ] just gonna bank as much
of that [ __ ] as i can bank
and um
yeah that's it
that's [ __ ] it and uh and as i said
that
i got a friend of mine
who builds cars
specifically trucks
and uh i've been toying with this idea
you know of getting myself a uh
an f250 high boy you know
with a displaced transfer case like
going to the real ones
and he goes you know why don't you just
make let me build you one i'm making
these [ __ ]
brand new f-100
dude you should have seen these [ __ ]
trucks
the suspension it was called a coil over
it doesn't have leaf springs it's just
these giant
springs like you'd have
like a motorcycle or a dirt bike he said
it rides like a [ __ ] cadillac and the
whole thing
looks like an old truck and then all of
a sudden like brand new technology like
you put it in reverse i can't i don't
want to give away all this guy's secrets
it's [ __ ] amazing
and i was looking at these trucks and
they're like i can't even tell you how
much money these [ __ ] things are
and all i was thinking is
i
want one of those [ __ ] whiplash weather
[ __ ] the fact that i already have
a car and an old truck
you know
[ __ ] that my carbon footprint is the
size of my head
that truck
would make me so [ __ ] happy would
fill the void
would that truck
be the one
that finally makes me
i don't know end the search whatever the
[ __ ] i've been searching for
and we all know the answer
yes
in the moment
without
a [ __ ] doubt
oh my god
i gotta tell you some of the [ __ ]
work that these guys that build cars the
men and women out there that are
building [ __ ] cars right
it's just it's [ __ ] unbelievable
every time you're just sitting there
going like you know what i think i've
seen
every [ __ ]
car that i like i started following
something last night well this guy just
basically has you know what people would
call pimp rides
but you know i i grew up in like the
suburbs so what i those pimp rides were
company cars
you know minus all the flare
that the pimps would put on them
you know
before they realized you know
that you know before gangsters realized
that basically
if you drive something flashy you
attract
the attention of the police the next
thing you know they start
bugging your phone you go to jail for
tax evasion
um
you know that was funny one time i was
doing stand-up and i heard this really
funny comedian
and she mentioned uh he or she i can't
remember
i was talking about al capone
and i was just thinking about how that
got that guy's reputation as one of the
great gangsters of all time
he's one of the most famous ones but
like
if you really read up on that guy all
the other mob guys were looking at the
guy like this guy's an idiot
you know
he's in the papers he's courting the
media and he's walking around in a
canary yellow suit like this guy's days
are numbered he was sort of like the
first you know teflon dawn
it's kind of funny when there's like a
mafia guy
that also wants to be on like the oc
right
like i really feel like mafia dons were
sort of the first like
you know reality tv sh you know show
stars
um
you can't say they were famous for being
famous
or whatever they you know they were the
ones
you know if you look at reality tv so
much of it is just basically
people fighting with each other and if
you look at the mob like that's
basically what they were doing it was
like the real housewives
you know
meets uh
i don't know the same the valentine's
day massacre or some [ __ ]
um
yeah and i just feel like it's it's
amazing that like that guy got all of
like this credit and there was all of
these other people
that were around during that time
you know
a handful of them i should say that
evidently kept their profile so low
people never even knew what they were
doing i mean dude that is when you have
you to to quote the seinfeld show
you are master of your domain
that you can literally
be running this criminal enterprise
okay and you're living next door to a
banker who is also running a criminal
enterprise but his is on the legal side
of stealing
so he gets to drive down the street
wearing a top hat with the cruella de
vil [ __ ] long
thing with this with the cigarette right
and just driving down the [ __ ] street
and one of those you know the ultimate
i'm better than you limousine where the
rich person is covered
and the chauffeur has a windshield but
no roof over him so he has to be out in
the elements getting a sunburn or
getting rained on or whatever
there hadn't been some sort of thing
that you could put over the [ __ ]
driver
um
and then the gangster next door had to
just sit there
knowing that he was he had more money in
the walls than this [ __ ] [ __ ] had
stuffed in his [ __ ] bank account
and just buy a more modest car and
probably not even live near the banker
and the smartest ones
from the beginning we're trying to go
legit
am i gonna sneeze god damn it why did i
smoke a cigar last night
so
the smartest ones
yeah they weren't trying to get further
into
you know
breaking the law and that [ __ ] they were
trying to gradually go legit
and i heard like rumors that there's a
couple there's like one major bank
and i'm gonna go scorsese here and i'm
gonna change the name and not you know
like when he says uh when you watch
casino he's always going our friends in
kansas city
because he didn't want to get in trouble
with the mob in a certain major city
that maybe doesn't get to respect it
deserves all the time
um
yeah this major bank evidently is was
started by the mob
because they were like why the [ __ ] are
we over here you know loan sharking
and when people don't pay us we got to
go out and break their legs and do all
of this [ __ ] and worry that they're
going to go to the cops
why don't we get on the legal side of
loan sharking and just become a
legitimate bank
and then if somebody defaults
our enforcers are now the police and
they can come over there and kick
everybody out and put their [ __ ]
couch on the sidewalk
and we'll get some other suckers in
there right
and that's the way it was
so
um
anyway
but i haven't said all of that
like um
yeah so they had these things these
company cars basically
is this
instagram account that i started
following i mean the picture was a 1977
lincoln continental
okay now who the [ __ ] is paying
attention to that car
all right but i remember when i was a
kid i remember those cars and i remember
when i saw somebody
driving
a lincoln continental or a cadillac that
meant one thing you
were rich
your wife
stayed at home
the meal was being taken out of the oven
as you pulled into the driveway
your children were afraid of you
you were probably banging your secretary
i mean it was status
i mean when i was a real
really little kid the guy across the
street always had a company car and
every year or two he'd get a new lincoln
continental and i remember in the early
70s that's how old i am i remember when
he pulled in
and he put the brakes on when he got to
the top of his driveway
his parking spot he had a green
continental and
it had like you know the brake lights
and then it had extra brake lights up
near right underneath the lower
windshield uh launch the lower part of
the rear
um
the [ __ ] the rear window jesus christ
someone said the rear windshield
the rear window and i remember just
thinking like wow
my dad has two brake lights that guy has
four brake lights
everybody in this neighborhood has two
brake lights but that guy has four
that guy
is the most successful man in the world
[Laughter]
i mean jesus where are those perks does
that do those perks exist anymore
that you get a company car actually what
am i talking about the gap between you
know they pretty much destroyed the
[ __ ] middle class you probably get
your own goddamn yacht
um
anyway i want to thank everyone that
came out to the terrace theater this
weekend
um that place will always be
um
you know that's richard pryor's place
man that is his stage
and uh i gotta tell you the first night
i went out there like i really thought
about that special a lot i was having a
great time
and um i just couldn't believe that i
was
walking
that same place if you ever see that
that um special
i brought this up in the last podcast
uh how it was uh
i always forget who the [ __ ] opened for
him
it wasn't gladys knight it was somebody
else
began with a g i forget
but um
[Music]
they had done a set and they got off
stage
and he just wanted to go out and they're
like people aren't in their seats yet he
goes no man i got to go now i got to go
now you watch me in that his special he
just walks out on stage
and when he takes the mic out of the mic
stand the spotlight isn't even on yet
he just picks it up he's like hello how
you doing he's just waving to people
what's going on
and then the spotlight comes on and
people are taking their seats and he's
just [ __ ] with the crowd like he's
hosting his own show like special or
something like that um
but i want to thank everyone that came
out and i had such a good time
a lot of friends came out hung out
afterwards man it was great um
so with that let's read some of the
advertising here for
for this week
oh look who it is everybody it's all zip
you know according to forbes
gyms nail salons hotels mom and pop
stores and more are set to go on an epic
hiring spree in the coming months
to meet the pent-up demand for all those
services oh this are they going to stop
uh
sending people checks
for not wearing masks
for being independent thinkers talk
about any business that you are
especially excited to return to or that
you've already returned to i want to go
to the movies
i want to go see that new james bond
um all of these businesses reopening
means that millions of jobs will need to
be filled so where do these businesses
turn
to fill these roles fast oh zip
uh right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
when you post a job on ziprecruiter they
send you they send your job to over 100
top job sites giving you
access to their network of millions of
job seekers zip recruiters matching
technology scans resumes to find
qualified candidates for your open roles
and proactively presents them to you you
can easily review recommended candidates
and invite your top choices to apply for
your job which encourages them
to apply faster
according to zip
internal data jobs where employers
invite candidates to apply get two and a
half times more candidates get two
and a half times more candidates zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five
employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day and right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
b-u-r-r that's it
dot com
just go to ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter
the smartest way to hire
um i don't know what that reads called
we're just like you know
that's the what the [ __ ] read you know
what the [ __ ] said recruiter
the smartest way to hire
the [ __ ] you waiting for
me undies me undies whiplash [ __ ]
weather do do do do me undies me undies
they even make them in leather
if you piss or take a [ __ ] it'll [ __ ]
catch it
on your taint whiplash weather between
your ass and your balls
um because you
i don't know took a [ __ ] laxative i
don't know what i was thinking i was
trying to combine whiplash with [ __ ]
underwear and i don't know
sorry about that sorry me undies sorry
for anybody who makes undergarments me
undies are you ready for mashed potato
season
aka turkey with gravy and cranberry
sauce season
jesus that's whip whiplash food oh bill
gross aka every kind of pie
and morse season
meundies is here with the softest and
stretchiest undies in the game
so you can be ready for seconds and
thirds
you won't even notice you're putting on
weight me undies believes that comfort
is more than what's touching your skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin even post thanksgiving dinner yeah
you don't want your underwear nagging
you you know what you did
that's like when you [ __ ] up and then
somebody said well what'd you do that
for
that wasn't very smart i know
you don't need your underwear nagging
you with adventurous prince to choose
from plenty of ways to match everyone in
the family giving your
gratitude some attitude this
thanksgiving season with me undies now
what do you do you have little
thanksgiving vignettes on the underwear
are they are they progressive
or are the old school history of what we
say that holiday is about they have
undies and loungewear made out of soft
breathable stretchy fabrics that are
perfect for everything from pre-dinner
activities to post-dinner naps seriously
you won't even care if the turkey is a
little dry yes you will
with undies this comfortable not okay
now i don't mind when it when a company
talks [ __ ] but if there's dry turkey
yeah that ain't happening available in
sizes extra small through 4xl in tons of
styles prints and fabrics meundies has a
little something for everyone at the
table meundies
has a great offer for my listeners for
any first-time purchasers you get 15
percent off and free shipping me undies
also has a promise if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason you can turn it you can you can
return
get all tongue tied there you can return
your order
for a full refund within 45 days to get
15 off your first order of free shipping
and 100 satisfaction guarantee go to my
undies dot com
that's mendes dot com slash bur oh look
who it is everybody it's simply safe
you know there's big news from my
favorite home security company
i know and you can also start your own
varmint reality show with simply safe
simply safe just launched their new
wireless outdoor security camera that's
right simply saved the best system that
the us that us news and world report
names best home security system of 2021
just got even better this brand new
outdoor security camera is engineered
with all the advanced technology and
security features
you want and need to help keep you and
your family safe it has an ultra wide
140 degree field of view so you can keep
watch over your entire yard it has
it has 1080 108
zero p hd resolution with eight times
zoom that means you can zoom in clearly
see things like faces license plates
paw prints to capture uh critical
evidence it has a built-in spotlight
with color night vision vision
so you can keep an eye on what's going
on at night it's super simple to set up
and usually just takes minutes and it
has easy to remove recharge rechargeable
battery so it doesn't need an outlet and
can go anywhere on your property
this home security
this camera has its has
has it all sorry and it integrates with
your simply safe home security system
extending its protection to the outside
together it means every door window and
room are protected and now your property
will be too to learn more about the
exciting new simply safe wireless
outdoor security camera
visit simplysafe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
winnie
what's more simply safe is celebrating
this new camera by offering 20 off your
entire new system and your first month
of monitoring service free when you
enroll in interactive monitoring again
that's simply safe.com
burr hang on
why i'm done with these things i'm
[ __ ] throwing them out
that's it i've had it
i [ __ ] had it
all right liquid four
you know discuss parts of your daily
routine that you think are critical to
your well-being like workouts yoga
meditation etc back bends baby
back bends are the biggest [ __ ] thing
nobody bends that way everybody bends
the other way right
everybody touches their toes and [ __ ]
you know little twisties at the back
nobody goes the other way and your psoas
gets super [ __ ] tight
right your shoulders roll in you become
internally rotated like you're trying to
hug a ghost and what is this guy holding
on to well he's been holding onto his
[ __ ] steering wheel for the last 40
years and never did a back bend you got
to do a back bend
but be careful
all right i'm not a workout person i'm
not a guru
like workouts yoga meditation etc okay
talk about how they help jump start your
day clear head space give you energy etc
cooler weather makes it easier to miss
signs of dehydrated dehydration
um or overheating or perspiration which
means even more important uh to keep
your body
which means it's even more important to
keep your body properly hydrated flu
season is in full swing proper hydration
and vitamins can help support a strong
immune system making hydrate hydration a
priority helps keep us healthier on a
day-to-day basis and fuels us to be our
high our highest potential our liquid
our stick of liquid 4 or iv sorry in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone
[ __ ] i need this stuff not only that but
the product tastes great with flavors
like watermelon
strawberry
and lemon and lime
are you going to be enjoying a few extra
drinks now that the holidays are
approaching this is what you need liquid
4 hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water and loan made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan
and free of gluten dairy and soy what
makes liquid 4 so effective cellular
transport technology the optimal rate
ratio of glucose sodium and potassium
delivers water and nutrients into the
bloodstream liquid four is on a mission
to change the world the company is
donating four million servings in
response to covet 19 products are being
donated to hospitals first responders
food banks veterans and active military
liquid iv
i keep saying four
liquid id has donated over 11 million
million servings globally grab your
liquid iv flavors nationwide at walmart
or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code bur at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code burr at
liquid iv.com
there you go
conspiracy theorists are going to be all
over that one huh
i don't know about that man we ain't
taking the vaccine and now they got this
liquid iv at [ __ ] walmart
seems like they're trying to inoculate
the rest of us
um response to last week's
who wants
hot uh dog to the girl who wants a hot
boyfriend oh here we go
here we go billy nut sack brains
you had a lady listener write in about
being a six or something
around that and wanting to be with a guy
that's a 10. being a lady listener and
rate my looks as a four hey welcome to
my world while my younger hotter husband
is at nine i felt the need to write in
girl it's no different for us as it is
for men who date harder partners it's
easier it's either you are a sugar mama
or got confidence through the roof guys
are not going to run after you
like they do the nines or tens but if
you play the long game like the funny
ugly guys do
you will bag a tent
uh what do i mean by this
don't act so thirsty for attention when
you are out with your much hotter
looking girlfriends be the comic relief
and not in a self-deprecating way do it
in a i'm smarter and wiser than everyone
look at this
yeah like i'd make a great mother these
[ __ ] will [ __ ] blow you
in the parking lot that's all they're
good for why are they [ __ ] because
they're better looking because you're
jealous bill okay maybe guys are just as
attracted to confidence as women are it
just doesn't happen right away because
they are slow and take a while to see it
you know just when i thought you were
going to compliment
men um no it's because we're we're
[ __ ] visually
we're wired that way
all right and uh yeah we get taken to
the cleaners because of that lastly get
your own damn interests and focus on you
as women we get told all kinds of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like you'll never get a husband
acting like that exactly or this will
make men like
like you if you stay skinny or dressed
this way or whatever [ __ ] everyone
and do you and you will get your 10.
right there exactly
this is what i'm waiting for every
[ __ ] feminist out there to do to stop
[ __ ] blaming guys
like that's all empowering [ __ ]
that's like that's what you just said
for women out there is what i [ __ ]
tell young comics
stop trying to write your [ __ ] acts
so the industry notices you go out and
do what the [ __ ] you want to do
go find your audience and let these
[ __ ] come to you
this is f i'm reading this [ __ ] you're
talking to women and i'm feeling
uplifting
i'm gonna go smoke a cigar no if all
that fails make a [ __ ] ton of money and
men will want to be your trophy husband
you don't want that go [ __ ] yourself
chub chubby girl with a hot younger
husband
well there you go all right
oh jesus speaking of cigar smoking
cigars smoking to pipe smoking i got to
go back to what this woman just wrote
i'm telling you
all right men and women can learn a lot
from what she just said there
that is the secret to success
all right
stop [ __ ] thinking about what other
do you go out and do what the [ __ ] you
want to do like you don't hurt anybody
do what the [ __ ] you want to do
believe in yourself
all right stop walking around trying to
find another [ __ ] parent
you know looking for everybody's goddamn
approval just [ __ ] relax
figure it out
baby steps each day
and next thing you know you're up the
[ __ ] mountain all right cigar smoking
to pipe smoking
dear b for bendetta
i don't know what that means i'm a new
listener i know v for vendetta i am
listening
i'm a new listener within the last two
years i am a south jersey guy hey had a
[ __ ] you doing and most of my knowledge
of you was your 2006 reprimand of the
local
philly crowd was that that long ago 15
years ago
i've really come to enjoy your podcast
yeah it'll grow on you if you keep
listening um
i have a five-year-old son and being an
older parent can relate to a lot of the
same things i lean conservative but i
appreciate rational thought rather than
party politics myself included something
that americans seem to have moved away
from lately
i tend to lean left
but like yeah if something makes sense
to me i don't give a [ __ ] what color the
tie is that's telling it to me
so
um
what is he says i'm an occasional cigar
smoker but really love
briar pipes and tobacco
aside from looking like an old man it's
a great way to sit back and relax and
force yourself to slow down
yeah i know
then you have a never-ending cold uh i'm
not sure if you're ever
if you ever considered pipe smoking i
tried it i can't keep it going there's
an art to it that i couldn't figure out
and then i was like do i really want to
figure this out
um because both my grandfathers uh
smoked pipes
and uh
it was funny they would just bust that
thing out
you know we'd be walking around faneuil
hall when they were in town
my grandmother would go in you know with
my mom or something to go look at
clothes or something and he would just
stand outside you know find a bench
just pop a little tobacco in he would
just sit there huffing on it was great
smelled amazing too
there are hundreds of tobacco blends
both aromatic and non
lots of taste to explore
collecting the different styles of pipes
is a lot of fun as well but again
socially society ranks tobacco smoking
just below apartheid in terms of
offensiveness
all the best to you
yeah i um
yeah it looks cool as hell to me and
[ __ ] like that but like i just have to
stop i'm not gonna throw my cigars out
i'm just gonna bring them down to the
comedy store
and get a bunch of other people hooked
on them that's a stupid thing i should
just throw them up i don't know but i'm
getting rid of them that's it
i'm done done
[ __ ] you
see you later all right hitler's pope
and sarah toga
dear billy the brick
long time listener first time writing in
was at the garden show the real one
uh plus mgm in dc
um i don't know what the real one means
uh the td bank north garden i mean
that's i mean the boston garden was the
real garden that's where the most
championships were won
all right don't get it [ __ ] confused
there was 21 championships one there 16
nba titles and five stanley cups
okay i don't know what happened in in
your garden if you're if you're trying
to talk
sports
you know or you're trying to talk about
respect and it's just like it's just
location it's in manhattan and everybody
wants to [ __ ] live there i guess that
that's what it is because it's certainly
not because of the success of those two
sorry-ass franchises that okay bill
going to the show in saratoga springs
this august couldn't believe it when i
saw
that place on your tour yes sir
if you've never been it's a beautiful
place a true oasis for
deegan
horse racing fans like me d-e-g-e-n
i don't know what that means uh you wait
well let's look it up let's see if
that's a spelling error
well if that's okay deegan
horse racing that's not coming up at all
inside nature's giants racehorses
i see just a big rack of ribs what's
that a [ __ ] glue factory all right i
don't know what you were trying to say
there um you're going at the peak of
racing season two fun time with a bunch
of bars in history and if you have time
to go to the races it's a great
experience filled with beautiful ladies
beautiful women it's uh the one horse
track where you don't feel like a
complete degenerate but rather a
high-class gent transported back into
the roaring 20s well what about uh
churchill downs that's how i felt when i
went there
um
a lot you know when you go to horse
racing i just felt like when you went to
the kentucky derby there was a lot of
people like
dressing the part of a degenerate
gambler
then it was actual like i probably think
like
the kentucky derby is like st patrick's
day for alcoholics like man i'm just
gonna stay home and drink
i ain't going down there with all those
[ __ ] yahoos
you know they don't know how to spend
their college kids college education
they're doing it ironically
um i recommend old brian's inn for a
meal
cool little stone tavern with great food
building is from 1773 and the rumor is
that george washington himself
and alex hamilton oh you're in a sort of
[ __ ]
um familiar
relationship with this guy you mean
alexander hamilton stayed there while
surveying battlefields
that's just a rumor that means they
didn't stay there uh really right
writing in though to discuss hitler's
pope
eugeno paselli
pius xii in the vatican
position during world war ii as you were
talking about it
on the 1018 podcast oh yeah they kind of
were uh
i don't know i think they were they kind
of were in the middle
and sort of probably rooting for the
germans
because they were going to try to put a
religion out of business
and that's the business they were in
right super interesting topic
and one that i actually wrote a massive
paper on way back in college that i got
an a for yeah yeah look at me a history
major in college why i don't really know
but it was fun at the time especially
being high during lectures
um anyway my stance ended up being that
he actually did all he could to help the
jewish people and just
treaded carefully around the nazis i
mean imagine being smack dab in the
middle of italy not only surrounded by
crazy mussolini but you've got a front
row seat to watch the nazi steamroll
through the continental through
continental europe in months with dive
bombing planes monster tanks and meth
out superhuman soldiers
yeah i mean people choose their own
survival yeah
he did a lot for the jewish people look
at this
included secretly sheltering jews in
various churches libraries and
monasteries held by the catholic church
well then why didn't they give the gold
back
why did jewish people have to knock on
the door and be like i believe you got
something that belongs to us
uh well approximately 80 of the jews in
europe
perished
80 percent oh my god during world war ii
85 percent of italians 40 000 jews were
saved it's reported no fewer than 3 000
jews
were hidden away
at castel
gandolfo the pope's summer residence
uh well all right look at that that's
what's a good thing for my religion who
knew didn't want to send the whole paper
as an attachment but here is
was my closing paragraph from it that
illustrates my position
well where did you get this information
is this from the vatican trying to
rewrite their history or is this true i
have no idea but you're the history
major we'll see overall
well the argument can be made that pius
the 12th
and calling him hitler's pope
there is simply too much evidence that
suggests otherwise
well then how the [ __ ] did he get that
[ __ ] nickname the reich conquered
that he made with hitler
was done to protect the catholic church
and prevent the violence that hitler
would have taken out against
german roman catholics had pius xii
condemned nazi germany
uh and gino pacelli never spoke out in
defense of the jews during the holocaust
because he knew it would only lead to
more innocent deaths he also yes it's
like [ __ ] cancelled culture really
bill you're really gonna get oh sorry he
also never needed the publicity defend
the jews because they need underneath
publicly sorry to defend the jews
because he was secretly protecting them
the whole time under hitler's nose
perhaps the best way to defend pius
xii's action during the third reich is
found in a speech made by albert
einstein albert einstein a jew
ironically ended the war the hitler
started with his creation of the nuclear
bomb only the catholic church stood
squarely across the path of hitler's
campaign
for suppressing the truth
i never had any special interest in the
church before but now i feel great
affection and admiration because the
church alone has had the courage and
pers and persistence
to stand for intellectual truth and
moral freedom
i am forced thus to confess that what i
once despised i now praise unservantly
well he also didn't know that they were
raping kids either
there's a lot of there's a lot of angles
to this
if one of the more brilliant men
uh in human history not to mention a man
of jewish faith said about said about
the catholic church
uh led by pius xii then how can anyone
argue otherwise
oh they can't believe me i have
follow-up emails coming in i bet uh and
gino pacelli or or pius xii was not
hitler's pope or an anti-semite but a
man who came into power during the
darkest days in human history and
navigated through hitler's nazi regime
with prudence morality and genuine
concern for the jewish race
well i hope all of that's true
um keep up the great work on all fronts
your podcast is a great way to end the
work day twice a week and i find many of
your takes insightful layered
and most important helpful look at that
would you look at that
i do matter i am doing nice things
now
i [ __ ]
picked four [ __ ] games last week
against the spread and once again i'm
3-0 going into the final [ __ ] game
the goddamn 49ers
[ __ ] me
just [ __ ] me i don't know what i don't
know what the deal was i don't know what
those [ __ ] corners were doing in the
first half
getting all confused on a little [ __ ]
uh little razzle dazzle behind the line
um how to ask out a bank teller
dear billy balding balls
come on guys can't you be a little nicer
to me man it's the holiday it's the
holiday season
a doobie dooby doo um
uh first i'd like to say that i recently
discovered your podcast a few months ago
and have
been tuning in every every week
dude this is what the guy writes first
of all i'm going to read exactly what he
wrote first i'd like to say that i
recently discovered your podcast a few
months ago and have tuning
ever week since then
i enjoy listening to you rant when i'm
at work i don't feel like i'm ranting
dude ranting is short for ranting and
raving i mean i got a little [ __ ]
upset about global warming
whiplash weather
climate change but i mean you know
i swear to god you i don't know maybe
that's why i am so [ __ ] up because
your guys idea of yelling is me just you
know making a point
um but getting to the point i'm 18 years
old and started working out this summer
and things have been going well that's
great i've gained some weight can
visibly see the change in my body with
that being said
when i still have my shirt on i still
look relatively skinny
dude that's great
you know someday in the future you're
going to wish you were still wiry and
skinny
i say all that to say that women don't
line up line up to be with me dude
you're only 18. you're already going to
talk yourself out of the game
there's this cute lady who looks around
my age who works at a bank
that i see every week and we've had a
few good conversations i'd like to know
your advice on how to ask her out
without being awkward or embarrassing
her in front of her co-workers thanks
and much love from arkansas all right
you go in there with the ski mask
freak her out like you're going to rob
her and then when she reads the note
you're just asking for her number i mean
that's one of the easiest ones ever
i would uh
yeah i'd slip her a note right under the
thing who gives a [ __ ]
you're making you deposit and everything
oh you just oh i got one more
transaction or something like that what
if you just [ __ ] write it out
either ask for her number
or give her your number
well i don't know what if you give ask
for her [ __ ] number
i've been out of the game for a while
man
if you give her the number then she has
to write hers down
do they pick it up on the security
camera
um
but i really think you got to write
something down because you don't want to
be trying to yell through that
bulletproof glass
you know do you have a boyfriend you
know
you don't want to sit out in the parking
lot and wait for her to come out on her
lunch break because that'll freak her
out
i think you just you know
let's see what did you say cute lady
around me and what you've even had a few
good conversations
just picture and you ask for a number
and she says no
and just listening to you scream [ __ ]
from the other side of that bulletproof
glass but it also is it's arkansas
is there even any glass there because
everybody's packing
good take your gun up i'd like to see
you try
um
yeah how to ask her out without it being
awkward or embarrassing in front of her
um i will be honest with you the
awkwardness and the embarrassing is just
all how you carry yourself
you know who gives a [ __ ] you like her
you're telling her you like her
you think she's attractive and you want
to take her out it's flattering
all right
get up to bat and take a swing
but i think i would definitely i think i
would write something down
you know
how would you do that man that
bulletproof glass is a real [ __ ]
barrier
i mean you don't want to like turn your
head sideways and try to yell through
where you put the money
[Laughter]
you just wanted your boyfriend
oh you know oh crap sorry all right
can you put 50 on my checking account
i'm not going to make eye contact for
the rest of this no i would i would just
write down on like a deposit slip
you know or something like that i don't
know
i guess i don't know that's a tough one
that's a tough one for me all right i'm
feeling like [ __ ] i'm gonna tap on and
make excuses here
i but i definitely think i think i would
write something down i would just ask
for a number i write on like a [ __ ]
deposit slip
no
withdrawal you write it on the
withdrawal you're making withdrawal
you're taking her out of the bank
if it's a deposit
it's only gonna go one way it's gonna go
on the other side of that glass and
nothing's coming back okay you okay for
the you need the mojo here you gotta ask
for her you asked for her number on a
withdrawal slip there you go final
answer
i'd phone a friend but i don't have any
all right that's it i gotta go [ __ ]
finish writing this goddamn
punching up this script
um if you're in california try to stay
dry today don't stand in front of a big
dry dirt hill because you might get
washed away with all the mud
all right that is it
um go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in
on you
on thursday maybe i'll do some shows
this week and i'll just hand out cigars
like i had another baby or something
that's it and that's not you know
it's not like i'm [ __ ] trying to give
you a little hint here all right i'm not
there's no gossip
all right
okay i'll see you